[Applause]
No good God
Big Jim can our weakest artistic Abba
get infected tooth Alice but humor to
show key back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey it's us again episode 48 yeah this
is a good one today I love this subject
this is a very good service this was
your idea actually that's right I'm
going to talk about the Mesoamericans
then yes about the mine the Maya yeah
yes not Mayan that's the only referring
to the language yeah you can say it when
you're referring to the language budgets
they're not the Mayans they're the Maya
yeah I grew up in South American Brazil
yeah as a teenager so I I love unlovely
the Mesoamerican said well I always
loved that I their iconography it just
seems it's so unique I mean I always
loved Egyptian stuff Egyptian stuff is
really cool but it's ela denies no
American stuff is like so yeah creepy
when I was there all the skulls and all
the intricate we don't work whatever
there was in the 80s so it's kind of
like a cross between for me if I want to
be was like it was like a cross between
Indiana Jones and Duran Duran always
like this that was it that's they're
funny because that sounds like a lot
like my eighties and even to enter
Heaven consume of everything early 80s
you know neither okay so before we get
to talking about the Maya weird about
mist about the Maya and we're talking
about facts about the mind I'm not
conceptions about the Maya often
actually truth is stranger than fiction
when it comes to the Maya but yeah much
I guess yeah yeah which in the antics
were a Maya breakaway we're get to it so
before that we're going to do a couple
of shout outs like we usually do first
thing we're going to talk about is
project Entertainment Network as usual
oh is you know on which our audio
podcast is hosted they're rad dude also
this upcoming weekend which is July 21st
through 23rd is the scares that care
charity weekend in Williamsburg Virginia
and several of the podcasters from
Project Entertainment Network including
the head of the network are Maude Rose
Amelia who is also horror writer will be
there so if you want to go there and
raise the money for a good cause and
stuff like that you can fear in the
Virginia area you can do that and
speaking of being in the area and
meeting people as usual we're going to
mention spooky Empire which is coming up
at the end of October so weekend before
Halloween as 27 to 29 I believe
and it's here in Orlando Florida is a
very large horror convention and it's
always a lot of fun and both Tom and I
will be there live in person that's
right you know anytime come see us yes
so we will be there signing books being
on panels yada yada so if you're in the
area at the weekend prowling then come
and see us and say hello also want to
give a shout out to where did the road
go part two of my interview about my
book the unseen hand is up now I don't
think part three is up yet not of this
recording anyway but part two is up and
also there are some extra bits of me
talking about the unseen hand about a
couple of poltergeist cases that are on
their patreon page that is for patrons
only
so if you want to go to their patreon
page which is patreon.com slash Suraiya
ASCAP I'll put a link in the description
if you want to go give them a couple of
dollars for their podcast I really like
where the road go it's a really good
yeah I just saw rise got a really good
show if you like our show you'd like
this too
yeah it's similar cuz paranormal type
topics weird etc so it's a really good
show and also again the unseen hand if
you ever purchased a copy yet then go
ahead and do that shall strong all now
they are very very good people seem to
like the audiobook which is nice people
might love my voice which I don't know
why whatever it sounds really weird to
me especially lately because I have some
kind of weird ear thing going on it
everybody talks that sounds like they're
talking through a pillow it really sucks
so I sound very weird to myself rotom of
the patreon oh ok also speaking of
patreon we are actually getting to the
point where we will be starting a
patreon soon yeah actually the show went
on much longer than I thought it's going
to go yeah you know but we're coming up
to almost a year right but wait I have
to make that we probably have about 2000
people uh regular listeners if you put
the podcast and at YouTube together so
you know hey may as well start a patreon
if they won't if they like to show they
wanted to continue coming we can make
the show priority yeah good we really
didn't intend to make this uh I guess
what regular show it just kind of it
kind of happened and I nautically
between doing this weekly show and doing
our new channel 3 channel
minutes doing the videos for that this
actually takes up quite a bit Holley
becoming a full-time job
it really is kind of or at least like a
lot like a part-time job but because
between all the research and doing all
the graphics and doing the recording and
sound engineering or whatnot and
especially now that we've started the in
minutes
I was thinking that I said you know if
even if just some of the people decided
all it's a couple bucks a month you know
we could assure quality and yeah it
would really help because I mean really
these take a long time to do but I
wanted them to be as good as we can make
them right and I mean if we had patreon
we could get like a better microphone
business alright but it's not more
elastic we could get better equipment
you can have more time and that's more
time it we can make more merchandise
stuff like that because I actually have
other you know I'm a writer too and I
also do a freelance graphic design
that's actually a large portion of my so
you know I have to take time out of yeah
you actually kind of kill some of the
graphic designs and focus more on this
and it would work out yeah that would
probably be good so I mean it'll
probably be a couple weeks before we
make like the big announcement well I
was thinking maybe we would do like the
big rollout like maybe on episode 50
okay which is a couple weekend weeks for
mouth mix he'll be our possession of the
thing we're going to Dec we we need to
cut pitch video yeah I also want to give
a plug to my blog goddess of Hellfire a
couple of you suggested as I go why
didn't you put a link to it in the
description I was like oh yeah I should
have done that so I'll do it from now on
but if you're into horror movies there's
a lot of horror movies horror books kind
of reviews I post on there I've been
doing it for several years but I just
now recently started putting a newer
reviews up there so if you're interested
in horror please go read that some of
them are funny Oh 13 o'clock in minutes
the new channel it's called 13 o'clock
in minutes I think it probably has about
there's ten there's yeah there's ten
videos up there now ten videos up there
now you put like I've been trying to
make one a week I can't always guarantee
that we can row take a long time to do
but I do have 10 up there and I have so
far been able to
whatever and everybody should go over
there and subscribe to that channel also
that'll move it up in the in the
algorithms yeah we'll start getting more
we also had a suggestion that I should
marry them and I don't know I don't know
maybe I could narrate some of them it
takes longer I could understand how if
somebody want to sit back and kind of
just technically hypnotically oh yeah
thing is is that Wow
the narration might get in the way well
I get it yeah I guess maybe I could do
some of them narrated I don't know like
I said they kind of take a long time
let's get to talk about the Maya but
before we do that if you are interested
in like Maya mythology or Maya
apocalypse type stuff there was a horror
anthology that came out I believe back
in 2010 and it was called 2012 ad it was
from severed press and I had a short
story in there called the five hills of
vacancy ho and it's a really good
anthology I have a copy and I've read
all the other stories and they're
they're really rad so if you if you are
interested in my a fiction Maya based
fiction or Maya mythology based fiction
you might want to pick that up it's a
really entertaining book I think and I
have a short story in there so you know
you can read some of my fiction if you
haven't done that alright so speaking of
my apocalypse let's start talking about
the Mayan 2012 deposit yeah I remember I
remember what they were talking about
that yeah feel like if people actually
think the role was going to end in 2012
laughing I think people I think money
Michael hoped it was going to end
whatever whatever they're talking
whenever there's some kind of an
apocalyptic thing going on there's
always what I always check this element
of people hoping that the apocalypse
would happen they're like yeah my
mortgage negative on to see awesome
don't know if the world's not going to
end you guys somewhere I got it but um
oh it'll land well yeah but not not
anytime soon
none of us are going to be here to work
except it so for us but you know as many
of you may know the the world did not
end in 2012 we're not speaking to you
from the afterlife or anything like that
but the perception that the world was
going to end because the Mayans said so
was because of a misunderstanding of
their Long Count calendar yeah typically
they have several calendars but it was
specifically their Long Count calendar
and if you see graphics on how the
calendar works it's quite cool as a
bunch of concentric wheels yeah three
interlocking circle
en glyph show up to represent certain
native you're making like a code for the
exact name of a day right that way each
day in the long count has its own name
yeah it's pretty cool yeah I mean the
one circle is actually just for
ceremonial and like religious dates and
then one of them is like a two hundred
and sixty day I think it's um like a
like a 13 months or something like that
and then the other one is the long count
now ironically they called the long
count the Mayan calendar but they didn't
actually not invent it no it's older
much older they're just one of the
cultures that use this particular
calendar configuration the thing is the
Long Count calendar started according to
the Gregorian calendar August 11 3114 BC
so that was when the world began
according to the Maya yeah now because
the calendar appeared to quote-unquote
end on the winter solstice 2012 people
thought that the actual world was going
to end it had to do with the changing of
the bat tune I think is what they call
which was the actual whole calendar now
recent reset to this way back to zero
zero back to zero that's all I mean
which I can see how people would have
that interpretation because some some of
the glyphs from the time do show like
varies gods turning up at the turning of
the resetting of the bach tune or
whatever so you can see how maybe this
would be perceived as a sort of like
apocalyptic event you know much like
Armageddon you know in the Christian
tradition tradition or whatever LARPing
tamiya probably wouldn't have considered
it to be the end anyway they just would
have now called it to bottom yeah it's
just the role of mekin just the role and
honestly I think in Guatemala illogical
sites in Guatemala they did find
evidence that the Maya believed that the
calendar would continue after that point
so they didn't think the world was going
to end necessarily we have some kind of
like resetting one of the weird things
that the modern Westerners don't don't
really realize about the Maya and this
probably goes back to Olmec and Toltec
even before then they seem to basically
worships time itself to a certain extent
not only this much of gods but time it
self was something to be venerated which
is kind of a weird contact and you can
kind of see this thread kind of running
through a lot of the ancient peoples
because so much of their life was
revolved around astronomy and revolved
around the changing of the seasons the
fertility the fields and things like
that you can see how how much importance
was placed on those type of thing I mean
it seems weird to us now but it wasn't
at all weird to them that I had to know
when the seasons would change yeah they
had some a long winnings exactly their
live window when we wind a plant right
when to reap your crops and all that and
when things went down bad things stopped
working correctly they always
interpreted as gods being angry to hit a
compensate because they would deplete
the soil around their cities yeah and
they're like why isn't it growing you
know why isn't it growing we did
something wrong we start sacrificing
people like I said you can't really
blend this with things like that so what
people like I specifically remember 2012
and know since the Maya didn't really
say what was going to happen
specifically all of these kind of crazy
things usually concerned around
astronomical things kind of turned up
about what was going to happen on
December 21st 2012 there was [__] like
oh there was that was like peak solar
activity which happens every 11 years
and it's not really that because
disrupts electromagnetic fields a little
bit but even the one that happened in
2012 was kind of minor so no biggie some
people predicted that the magnetic poles
of the earth would flip-flop when one
day right which the magnetic pole and if
you didn't know it does just but it
takes it's gradual it's so gradual that
there's no disruption in the fossil
record I think the last time it happened
was like 780 thousand years ago or
something like that so it does happen
just not like immediately and it doesn't
really have an effect on life on the
planet
there was also if they were like a black
hole would come and swallow the earth
one of my favorite ones was that the was
that Planet X put our you know ever
notice in your Bureau it was going to
smack into the air yeah which one that
plan is not there that's what it was it
long ago they said look if it was going
to hit the earth in December 2012 we
went our seeded
it would have been as bright as Mars in
April of that year like coming at you if
it was coming at you at you know these
kind of legends in these kind of tales
you know they're not about logic it's
about feeling and imagination yeah
that's true and people kind of hoping
that there's a planet coming this is a
little history yeah I guess but there
are mysteries but there's enough
mysteries you don't have to make more
yeah that's why I always said like I
love like I am super skeptical of pretty
much everything you know yeah and but
it's like I love mysteries as much as
the next person but I don't like to
invent mystery where there isn't one and
if there's not a mystery I want to know
that it's not a mystery right I want to
know what's really going on by that so
it needs us to say that my encounter
2012 stuff didn't happen because we're
still here yeah all right they also said
there was going to be a planetary
alignment and that was like yeah big
whoop there's planetary alignments all
the time there was one in 2000 there
were in 1982 and it's like it doesn't do
any nothing happened so you know chill
okay so aside from all the kind of
apocalyptic stuff about the Mayans which
are Maya which obviously didn't happen
there are also a lot of stuff about
there's a that all the ancient alien
types of stuff
Atlantis that they didn't really build
the pyramid blossom like a witch you
kind of get about all ancient cultures
really which to me I'm gonna be hoping
yeah it always like super racist right
because I'm always thinking oh those
poor ancient people were too dumb to
figure out how to build their business
yeah so like oh they must have obviously
had extraterrestrial help all right
because they can ridiculous look ancient
people were no dumber than people today
real and you have to think it's not like
the ancient Egyptians or the ancient
Mesoamerican we're sitting around going
boy are sure where somebody would invent
the wheel or would invent a backhoe or
something like that they just worked
with what they had just like everyone
else does right and a lot of the
motivations to build these things were
exactly the same motivations you had to
day to build skyscraper
it really really revolve around money
and power even like the Great Pyramids
of Giza it was about money and power
even though it was cloaked in religion
there was built by a construction
company yeah we know that those were
built by construction companies all the
little blocks are encoded with numbers
to tell you what teams built it
so there was a lot of money involved in
building that thing even though the
Egyptians didn't have money they trade
it was kind of a barter system it was
about money in power and like I said
people either think that
extraterrestrials either directly built
the pyramids or told ancient peoples how
to build the pyramids and there's also
some other that's used us in the Erich
von Daniken's and chariots of the gods
section there's also there was also a
guy named Ignatius Donnelly I think as
Namor and he came up with the idea this
was in the late 1800s that Atlanteans
you know had given them the knowledge of
how to do it because again they were too
dumb to figure it out evidently but the
stupid thing is the whole fulcrum of his
argument was that well it must have been
Atlanta ins because look at how similar
the ancient Egyptian pyramids and the
Mesoamerican pyramids are and I'm just
like what pyramids are you looking at
son because they are not similar and
they were used for different things and
there was a huge gap in time between the
two I mean you have to think the oldest
Mesoamerican period of the oaep pyramid
was mm I mean the Egyptian was worth to
like 2,000 years older than that right
so there's like a huge down time they're
not they're not related at all they're
not even built the same way no and the
ancient Egyptian pyramids were generally
you know it was one construction event
they're like okay we're going to build
this pyramid which stage that change is
generally used us to and we're going to
build it and however long it took and
then they would build it until it was
finished the Mesoamerican pyramids were
built over generations and they kind of
added on to them like they would add new
levels and stuff like that now there are
very few of them that were found that
were used as tombs they were usually
just ceremonial basically staging areas
yeah they would have like temples at the
top they would do sacrifices on them or
whatever they were kind of like a city
center type of thing that everyone could
gather around and see things so and like
I said they weren't all built in one go
like it wasn't one problem whenever I
would ever be a royal families would
change out they would usually put a new
face over over the temples to make it a
little I can ooh civilization
new epic in the city in the city's right
three because you know all these old
Mayan cities were not really unified
most of the time these are kind of good
analogy would become like the Greek
city-states yes very similar and they
were a rat they were pretty much around
the same time period rock record Roman
era and the Mesoamerican RNA actually
didn't last long if I remember correctly
the average age one of those cities is
only about a hundred years 150 years
before became uninhabited so this whole
idea of do you know the mean that like
oh they disappeared one day look at all
these ruins they wouldn't abandon cities
after a while yeah and actually we're
going to get into that later because
that's kind of one of the most
interesting things that one of the
budget doesn't miss yes that the
advantage and then there's this big
mystery but it really wasn't a mystery
to build a city to build a city they've
run into a grant run it into the ground
the government would get overthrown
chaos and rain and they don't run
because he each city was its own state
and like I said I kind of wanted to get
into that bar or like I didn't hit it
yeah like after the break because I was
kind of talking more about the
paranormal stuff like a Hornet okay so
also so we talked about ancient aliens
pyramids obviously that's [__] there
was also some people that thought
because they found skulls in Mesoamerica
that were elongated so some people
thought that had some kind of alien
significance this is not the case
obviously what they do and actually some
tribes now still do it also they do head
binding they take a baby and they have
very served diagrams on the internet if
you want to go look and they kind of
flattened its head as it grows so it
grows into that particular shape it
wasn't done to everybody it was usually
just done to nobility and they did it
because they wanted to distinguish
themselves from the commoners and also
because they believed that their gods
wanted them to look that way that that
was more attractive to the gods and
that's pretty much all it was but you
can see some pretty weird
examples of these really basically
elongated yeah skulls that are really
very odd-looking but it's a similar kind
of thing to some you know some of the
tribes that used to put the rings in
their necks to make the long necks and
things it's a similar kind of thing now
there's a thing called a Starchild skull
yeah yeah
and it's an anomalous skull then
everybody says aliens is not a no it's
not
I'm tell if there's something whatever
something wrong with that baby yeah it's
obviously a child skull there was
evidently lots of inbreeding in in mine
Society
yeah they had a lot of birth defects
this particular now I can't remember the
name of it but this particular deformity
that this is all has it looks very much
like it might be called cyclops cyclops
syndrome I've seen pigs with it stuff
like that where where your nose and the
eyes don't develop correctly and then it
looks like you just have one tiny little
eye and kind of like no no it's so the
Starchild skull kind of looks like a kid
with that deformity all right I think
it's called but it's done it correct me
if I'm wrong yeah there's been different
tests on it you know they sendeth e-bay
the entire skull is made out of the same
thing tooth enamel is made out of you
know I don't know but it is see I kind
of dull it look at me it looks like a
regular kid skull that's deformed yeah
it does look like a normal human skull
that yeah it has teeth anomaly it's not
no way is it alien that is homo sapien
and there's also a little bitty tiny
little tiny human skeleton that's
emerged is it right I remember Sam I'm
learning about that that is also human
it's human but it is small it's only
like five inches long it's weird I feel
like people don't see this a lot
particularly in the West there's this
really good book I think it's just
called mutants I read it several years
ago where they talked about all
different kinds of deformities that have
been seen in humans and stuff you would
be alarmed or out there well what it was
out there for how common it is yeah I
mean a lot of these are really really
common like I said you don't really see
it much in the West because you know we
have amniocentesis and you know and
during your pregnancy you can see things
turn you find some stuff some weird
stuff just right there on YouTube yes
it's happening in the Middle East where
they don't use amniocentesis and a lot
of that stuff as much as it babies are
coming out pretty weird like some of
those like mom a baby that's like that
yeah it's like really weird-looking so
like I said it's you know left to its
own devices nature will [__] up your
babies like really pretty good that's
pretty commonplace so you know it's just
now with the advent of like kind of
modern medicine and stuff like that that
you don't see it as much but yeah
so the skull that that skull it's not
alien obviously now since we're speaking
of skulls we also have to talk about
crystal skulls yeah because when you
talk about Maya there's that's a pretty
common thing to crisperizer especially
that horrible horrible Indiana Jones
murder that I liked all the other ninja
God that in Lucas boy he can look over
he can looka five that was a really [__]
movie and well the thing is I liked the
concept but just the whole it was like
an Indiana Jones parody it was that's
exactly what it was like that's exactly
it was like this it was it was almost
kind of like the second would escape
from LA yeah it was almost a parody of
escape from New York
you know I love scape from New York yeah
and I actually like skate from LA but
it's a parody yeah pretty much pretty
much and the thing about Indiana Jones
in the Crystal Skull this is how sucky
it was I thought the first time I saw it
I was on an airplane and I couldn't tell
if it was the plane ride or the movie
that was making me nauseous
yeah sure oh you know what it was just
bad bad bad and I thought again like
hoping oh maybe we shouldn't be me being
on a plane but now it sucked
okay Crystal Skull these are pretty much
generally so oh it's like the
Mesoamericans and they made these
beautiful crystalline and I pop my hand
high polished and stuff like that and
there are several examples in various
museums now every single one every one
of them that had been subjected to
scientific scrutiny and they've all been
subject and they all all the one so far
that they have found been subject is
they are modern their mom they were made
after the middle of the 19th century
most of them were probably made in
Germany and there was a town in Germany
where there were a bunch of workshops
and they were because they know that the
courts that the adults were made out of
was probably came from Brazil but there
was a particular town in Germany that
was kind of known for having all these
workshops of making like all these
really cool objects out of Brazilian
quartz or not just called but obviously
all of the skulls have been worked with
modern tools yeah that's the dead
giveaway you look at the thing with a
microscope and you can see the polishing
marks from electric tools yes they've
used tools that were not invented until
after the rebel of the 19th century
rotary tools and some of them used you
know various
chemicals and things like that that
weren't in use until the 20th century so
they're all pretty much debunked devant
not that they aren't beautiful they are
not that they're not crystal skulls they
are fertile god they're just not
Mesoamerican they're not old which I
don't want to [__] on the crystal skulls
because like I said as art objects they
are really beautiful right but there's
just not but you don't have to like add
on by saying oh they're old and
Mesoamerican other place no they're not
you know they're not handmade they were
made by tools but they're still pretty
eyes you know so I don't understand why
people get disappointed about that so
probably most of them are from Germany
what we're going to do now because I
wanted to kind of get into the
quote-unquote disappearance of the of
the Maya conquest and I wanted to get a
little bit into human sacrifice too
right so we're going to go more to the
historical fact yeah so um you know
we're getting up to halfway point now
anyway so let's kind of take a break
right now and then we will come back and
talk more about kind of historical type
of things so we'll be back in just a few
minutes
once upon a time a madman poet in thief
known as Jonathan sick that's me
challenged himself myself to write a
story every day for a year by hand some
of them worked some of them things some
of them were spectacular then I did
again join me every week for ink stains
as I do it a third time and I will read
you some of these stories I'll talk
about the process about creativity in
general writing and specific and maybe I
can help if not your artistic adventures
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon subculture corsets and
clothing is our favorite store for
unusual clothing shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that's
subculture corsets calm make sure you
use the discount code 13 o'clock for a
10% discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 three times with
the ads the usual gang video that need
printer gold a New York Times
bestselling authors my name is Jim more
interviews with pop-culture stars and
creators I'm John King library and they
don't talk about politics course of
events but important event today I
certainly don't talk about politics
I suspect weekend our rule that no
particular to talk about politics
didn't you say they don't talk about
politics if somebody else says something
we should thank you anyone hear me am i
all alone here three guys with beard
Tuesday's exclusively on project
Entertainment Network
[Music]
you
all right now we're back talking about
them bhaiyya now is stranger than
fiction
usually well here's the thing the thing
that and I think this is probably one of
the most common misconceptions about the
Maya that they just quote-unquote
suddenly disappeared no they're still
there well yeah they're filled at six
million there's no why are you guys his
eyes there is no lava buzzer and I
lanterns a lot of other areas very oh
I'm still speaking that language yeah so
you know they didn't really go anyplace
right really what happened it wasn't so
much a collapse as it was kind of a
dispersal I feel like what they think
happened now visit and it didn't have
anything to do with the Spanish we
cannot banish Barron on Cortes didn't
get there until 1525 historians placed
the Maya civilization into two periods
which would be the classic period and
the post classic now the classic period
ended in 900 CE or ad if you prefer so
it was several hundred years after their
kind of big heyday that the Spanish even
showed up right what ended up happening
they think I mean they're not entirely
sure but there were a lot of factors
going on at the time that contributed to
this collapse if you want to call it
that or dispersal or whatever and I'd
also recommend if you haven't read it I
mean most you probably read it but
collapsed by Jared Diamond and he goes
into this goes into his theory about
what happens in great detail but
generally what happened mostly was kind
of an environmental catastrophe
Mesoamerica was not sustainable that
culture and that civilization was not
sustainable it needed more technology to
actually support its population density
there's a lot of problems with it and
there's the this myth that was at 500
Spanish conquistadors came and collapsed
this civilization the total myth he
actually read what Hernando Cortes did
it had more to do with Hernan and a
bunch of his Indian allies overthrowing
the despotic regime of the Aztecs and
then Hernan not getting what he was
promised by the span
government that was really what happened
and also the Mayans abandoning their
religion in favor of Catholicism that's
really kind of what happened in the big
picture but really okay so before the
Spanish even got there like I said
hundreds of years this is before the
Year 900 which like I said is wouldn't
consider the end of the Classic Maya
period of their civilization now you
have to imagine at this stage before 900
they had massive cities some of these
cities could accommodate a hundred
thousand people adjust their metropolis
inside more or less when Hernan Cortes
his men saw the very first Mayan city
and this wasn't even a first-tier city
it was one of the second or third-tier
cities they own what they all mutiny
because it's the biggest thing that they
had ever seen it was painted turquoise
it had red trim on it and they all ran
back to the ships and Hernan burned the
ships yes I said it's a good run that's
that some of them back to go get
reinforcements some of the ships left
and then they went on their mission and
there they basically use diplomacy there
wasn't enough Spaniards to use force it
was a lot more complicated than kind of
shown in the movies Hernan Hernan had
Indian Indian wife a bunch of Indian
children he was a teenager when he
showed up really study Hernan Hernan
Cortes his stories is really cool if you
had if you had a chance you should hear
his story but yeah so but like I said
before the Spanish even got there
several hundred years for Spanish even
got there their cities had already been
significantly depleted like I said the
Maya were still there they were just
spread out farther what ended up
happening they think was a combination
of environmental factors and a few trade
factors as well what they think happened
they basically expanded beyond their
natural resources yeah so they were
building these gigantic cities which
would in turn attract more people which
would mean they would have to make the
cities bigger and that they would have
to clear more land for agriculture now
they were taking down so many trees and
clearing so much land for agriculture
that now when you clear such large
tracts of land
you were going to and environmental
sciences that have studied this period
they think that there was already a
drought at this period now the Maya has
dealt with a few droughts before they
weren't done they knew what they were
doing but at this point they had
deforested so much of the land and it
cleared so much of the land that you
know when you clear so much land the
solar you you don't get as much solar
radiation reflecting back you don't get
as much precipitation yeah you don't get
as much about what's the water sucking
back up from there what's the word for
that evaporation thank you Jesus Chris
come again I'm getting old seriously I
can't remember words anyone but yes you
don't get as much information so you
don't get as much clouds you don't get
so much rainfall now then since it was
already kind of a drought situation
going on at the time and then since
there was so much to forestation so it
made the drought situation worse they
were cutting down the rain forest yeah
it made the drought situation much worse
than it had been previously so obviously
you have a drought situation you're
going to have your crops failing which
is going to call it famine it's going to
cause disease it's going to cause
intercity fighting it's going to cause
various other things now here's another
thing is that they also had no
agricultural technology they need to
know about fertilization they irrigated
a bit but I don't think they knew about
fertilizing soil they didn't rotate
crops you know they yeah they did have
some problems with soil eliminating yeah
they were just I mean it's been going on
for hundreds of years committed and fine
but they had so much rainforest to
spread out into and the evidence was
showing that they were depleting the
soil around yeah they eventually got to
a point where it just wasn't sustainable
anymore skeletons love the skeletons in
the in the later parts of each one of
these old city areas or urban areas
which show like signs of malnutrition
which that they weren't getting enough
to the caloric intake yeah not a
balanced diet they were probably just
mostly sort of trying to survive off a
corn and maybe a rat yeah
and then there was obviously one where
it's not worth it to live in the city
yeah and there was there was also a
thing to wear during this time period
they were kind of transitioning now
before this period they had used mostly
land-based trade routes but it was kind
of slowly transitioning over to more sea
based trade routes which meant that a
lot of farmers and craftsmen and stuff
like
they wanted to sell and trade their
wares then they would have to generally
move to you know closer to the sea
closer to the new trade centers so there
was kind of a lot of factors going on at
the time that encouraged people to leave
the cities and kind of disperse into
other areas you know it wasn't a kind of
case where everyone just left one day I
mean it took several hundred years yeah
like about 150 years although there are
there is evidence of cities being
abandoned rapidly some of those cities
had signs that they were abandoned like
within a few days because of turmoil
because there would be sculptures left
undone not all those the cities were
abandoned at the same time yeah that's
what I mean and honestly some of them
like some actually pretty large cities
we're still largely occupied I mean up
until the 15th century huh like I said
this kind of myth of the sort of sudden
collapse like everybody just laying all
day or they all vanished and went
somewhere be UFOs came down Ghana and
didn't happen yeah they came down with
the death rays of just purely Mars
Attacks everybody but yeah that did not
happen it took hundreds and hundreds of
years
good analogy was that UFOs did not come
down and take the ancient Greeks they
didn't come down and get the Romans
either yeah this is it to me it's okay
this this is another thing that seems
very weird like I don't ever see anybody
attributing the fall of Rome like that
an alien yes but for some reason
Mesoamerica everything is suddenly like
oh they just left what I meant like
disappeared and you know what I mean
that's just really weird why why just
that specific I think so many made up
this story in the 60s maybe because it
really got on it going down there one
day only taking peyote with the Indians
and coming up with crazy ideas and write
them down and I suppose but it just
seems strange that that's kind of the
only civilization to people really I
mean that they just had to get out the
way the way the glyphs look and the way
all the sculptures look it looks kind of
extraterrestrials kind of alien it's
hard to interpret what's being well you
know like what a Western person looks
some of these drawings that the Maya
made even the f-d-a sticks also it's
hardly hard to interpret what you're
seeing yeah because you don't know what
a Mayan headdress looks like you don't
know how the style of art what they're
drawing you're not really from
you're with it yeah have you ever seen
with some of those glyphs or say like a
Mayan warrior who's dancing got
something on his head you don't know
what the hell that is
ya know like what's on his head not the
way it really looked and that was like a
headdress that they that they yeah you
know I feel like people are more data I
mean the Egyptian stuff look looks
pretty weird too but I think it's so
ubiquitous now yeah people are kind of
used to it I don't think the
Mesoamerican good stuff gets as much
play maybe the Egyptians they're not
quite as well known honey you know when
you look at some of the like a Mayan
glyph or a picture of something
happening like three or four people
sitting around one of them guy's fingers
bleeding the other ones doing this and
there's smoke coming up and there's
skulls and the guy's headdress you don't
know what you're looking at but when you
have somebody who studied the whole
religious religion and the mythos and
everything they can explain you exactly
what's being shown and what it means and
then you go okay yeah it makes total
thanks just like in context it all makes
sense just like every other religion
does everything everything right you
know and you can see how they came to
believe that and how their stories like
developed around that those sort of
ideas but you know as we were saying
before so by the time the Spanish got
there one that so they had been depleted
somewhat or dispersed rather obviously
the Spanish army didn't help that is
true that the Spanish did have diseases
that many Americans were not immune to
so that didn't help matters and they you
know they also had iron and gunpowder
and things like that that the
Mesoamericans did not have but it still
took the Spaniards almost 200 years to
completely subjugate really the last
defeat of one of the Maya cities was not
until almost 1700 yeah but Cortes
writings demonstrate though that the
gunpowder and the steel and all that
really didn't make a tactical advantage
don't feel like illogical well because
the thing is the Maya were ambushed yeah
warriors and you know what's a what's a
flintlock rifle how's that going to help
you fighting a damn enraged concert rock
concert that's what it was like but yeah
in a rock concert you got one shot off
and that was it you know the Mayans had
good weapons technology it was like a
flat stick kind of like a baseball bat
was flattened with obscene
shards of they had a city in blades they
had bows and arrows so does that mean
they were familiar with the terrain two
Spaniards were not and that could take a
limb off of a single bloated lessor very
ragged wounds and you bled to death
quickly you know they had good stuff
yeah most of the fighting actually was
done by Indian allies of Cortese
yeah because jumping of the Mafia now I
some of them did alive themselves with
him early on because there were a lot of
factions that were infighting it was
more like a revolt was a revolt again as
Tex and the Aztecs were not you know
they weren't you know all real good
people either you know I mean they
weren't all you know they were kind of
like the Nazis of the gods Mesoamericans
they had subjugated all the state states
around them and it was a totalitarian
regime that was pretty brutal yeah but
I'm not sure how unusual that was for a
Mayan civilization but the founder was
supposed to be pretty much a psycho I
mean he skinned his bride on the wedding
night and wore her skin in front of the
father during a wedding feast that's a
pretty [__] up yeah I wore his Brides
skin that's the max a shilling where he
actually he didn't wear the skin he put
the skin on one of the priests it had
something to do with the causing rain it
was like a sacrifice to a rain God says
bizarre and because of that they got
kicked out yeah and all the all the
Aztecs got exiled and they ended up
finding a place to live out in Lake Ashi
Milko that's where the Mexicans that's
where the Aztec capital city was it was
built on an artificial island that
you're selling in cents a mile I saw the
aspects of now the Maya did some pretty
brutal [__] too but like that were like
throw that they were that much too much
even for us yeah that's too much yeah
yeah
the Aztecs were no joke yes we're
absolutely no joke that's that's very
high yeah and then found their founder
wasn't like taking a psychopath yeah
well since we're on the topic of
gruesome things and stuff like that
let's talk about human sacrifice all
right yeah because that's something that
the Maya are also kind of known for yeah
and this is something that kind of gets
gets brought up a lot there's kind of I
don't think there's so much nowadays but
there used to be kind of this whole
thing about oh the ancient people and
they were peace love and everything like
obviously that's not true no it's not
sure but I don't think they were
necessarily that much more savage than
modern people if there's kind of if it's
kind of a gray area like always it's
like yeah they do Savage shape people
nowadays be savage [__] it's like not
you know human sacrifice the despite a
lot of a lot of civilizations did it
back then this is the Spaniards were
appalled
one of the first neighbor I saw was they
saw mezzo mezz tech priests sacrificing
little girls in her honor of their
arrival Spanish conquistadors were
preserved and killed some of those
priests and it almost it was a massacre
from day one which is understandable
when you look at it from today the
Spaniards were Catholics they saw this
as devil worship and they really
wouldn't be wrong because the spend the
Aztecs
some of the Aztec gods were Devils no
they did venerate them but it wasn't so
much of it worshiping Devils as gods or
your Creator per se they were trying to
bribe these Devils off so in other words
if you can do it sacrifice to the demons
to prevent something bad from happening
so they were kind of like bribing the
devil well you know the Spaniards
weren't having that and it was sometimes
human sacrifice involved in bribing off
these Devils they did weird stuff they
had underground caves filled with dead
bodies on Marion marionette strings and
they would take sacrifices and walk them
down through there show them what hell
was going to be like in the underworld
is going to be like come out the other
end and then they walk them up into a
temple and cut their hearts out they
were hardcore they also took a lot of
psychedelic drugs or no oh yeah it was
oh it was a Pantheon istic religion like
you know ancient Greek religions but it
involved you know like the Titans which
would become like their version of the
Devils yeah that they needed to be
appeased it was a good one young guy and
the bad ones from this fad from a point
of view of a Spanish Catholic there's a
straight-up devil worship and nothing
they treated it as such now it was all
written down later on of Spanish friar
went down there and recorded all the
beliefs and the names of the gods and
made a huge thousand-page book you know
it took him years to write it he sent it
back to the that
and just sat there in a vatican library
unread for centuries
pretty much everything we know comes
from that book everything else was
burned except something called The
Dresden codex which is which survives in
Dresden Mesoamerican priests gave it to
this Catholic priest includes you know
save this this is basically the last
document of our civilization and the
meaning of everything really it's been
translated now it's basically just the
instructions about what the Long Count
calendar is and force in explanations of
the Four Seasons that's really all I
left i from from memory it made it a
little bit more than that pretty weird
anyway it was a weird religion but quite
cool quite cool it is I've always found
it very interesting and just because
like I said it doesn't seem a view Bick
wa tiss in western culture or european
culture as you know Egyptian mythology
greco-roman mythology it seems like it's
almost sort of given short trick because
it's a new world and all that other type
of thing but I've always found it really
fascinated but I don't know if they
would have necessarily seen it that way
it had enough of the pre the book that
the priest wrote put everything down in
Christian analogy so in other words they
said some of these rain goddesses were
kind of a good analogy of say like the
Virgin Mary and that some of these other
you know figures might be might have a
good analogy would say like the
Archangel Gabriel but then some of them
would be like okay a good analogy with
this one is like the demon of death or
the devil himself you know so they had a
bunch of different figures and they had
to venerate them all yeah keep the
system working face because I mean just
like a lot of ancient peoples they
thought well we have to appease the gods
so that they won't [__] us over
Roger that we'll have a good crowd that
you know our people will be fertile so
you know we won't have bad weather or
whatever what they were doing they also
had a really good Warrior Ethos
everything was about fighting their
warfare was religious it was about
getting sacrifices you went out and you
fought some other guys who were
basically the same religion as you from
another city and you could defeat them
in combat and take them back as living
captives and sacrifice them to the gods
to pay back the blood debt now what's
funny is that these sacrifices these
captive sacrifices are going to the top
of the
temple without any struggle because if
their religious duty to do so they
believe if there were with this
religious group well they'd be doing the
same thing to the other day because
evacuation was rumor it was more like a
sport they did generally most of these
sacrifices that they made if you saw the
movie Apocalypto that's actually pretty
accurate accurate that's what they would
do they would paint the people blue they
would take them to the top of the
pyramid you know they would have a huge
big ceremony everyone would come to see
it everyone would be taking
hallucinogens it would be a party and
then they would behead the guy and cut
his heart out of you know one of the
other that wasn't the only way they
sacrifice people they had a few other
methods sometimes they would paint a
person blue tie them to a post and then
have everybody take turns shooting
arrows at them sometimes they would
laden people down with gold and jewels
and stuff and then throw them into the
cenote ya know that big horrible single
yes so generally who they sacrificed
you know slaves or prisoners of war they
like to sacrifice orphans orphan
children bastard children yeah
criminals yeah you know things like that
children I think we're kind of their
favorite sacrifice because if their
innocence to their blood was supposed to
be pure or whatever generally I think
most of those sacrifices were captured
carriers or captured plates from other
night in Apocalypto they just show him
capturing like a random forest tribe and
then taking them to sacrifice yeah
more likely would have been one city
capturing other city guys yeah
sacrificing them in their City history
mostly mostly dempster shows that that
that was happening
one city would start fighting in another
city yeah a certain time of year usually
it was like a ritualistic combat okay
this is the time of year which we have a
war
this is fighting time by done I know
we're going to go fight that City over
there they're going to beat us out in
the field and we're going to somebody's
going to get captives and then yay we
can sacrifice now when the city was
doing bad those according to witnesses
Western witnesses when the seas were
doing bad you know they when you ecology
was screwed up and it was a lack of food
it was ordered these sacrifices not only
a month warriors but of the general
population so you could reduce the
population and when they would kick the
heart lifts or head
body's back down those temples where
they didn't get pile up around the
bottom of the stairs and people in the
crowds would grab those bodies and run
off with them because they were eating
them we got free meat so they were
recycling the recycling population it
sounds terrible but when you're starving
you know now the Spanish reported that
in the Mayan capital city there were big
structures like pens about the size of
the three-story building made of skulls
on racks and in there lots of bodies and
you know it was nasty the place stank
around the temples and some of those
temples were an inch thick and dried
rotten blood with maggots in them and
stuff it was not a pretty sight there
were lots of reports of ritual
necrophilia to keep momentum vivid to
keep mummified kings satisfied ah weird
stuff like that yeah yeah oh my god we
the whole show and Dekker Fillion you
walked out you were sober so and still
people still to this day I still get
comments about how muddy there is
because of you having that little bit
feel like I'm out of here that was
everybody one of the one of the coolest
things this is one of the coolest things
when I was research in the show was I
was reading a lot of like a you know
Maya creation myths and stuff like that
and kind of similar to the
judeo-christian creation myths were all
more familiar with the Maya also had
they had kind of four creations and
there were kind of separate creations
but the animals were created first and
then there was wet clay that was the
next creation and then the third
creation was wood which got it's kind of
cool because the kind of shows that
shows like the the very varying
importances of the things other than
cultures making you and then the forest
with humans and the humans were made out
of maize dough or corn dough that's what
I'm blood yes love taken from the Sun I
don't know I just I always thought that
was like really baffling there was
another one where it was more of an
Aztec creation myth story that I
remembered this just off the time ahead
of me may have it wrong one of their big
gods was called with Tila patia because
with
how you pronounce it and he took his
either his bride or his sister I don't
remember and tied snakes around her arms
and legs and then chopped them off and
threw her through her torso down from
heaven and along with the arms and legs
and somehow that created the earth I
don't understand that I like the
Egyptian myth of Isis and Osiris yeah
very similar to that now when the
Spanish took over one of the capital
city they buried a lot of those statues
from the mine and religion and a statue
of that survives in a museum I think
it's still in Mexico and it's a huge
disk probably about 14 diameters stone
maybe about four feet thick and it's a
woman and almost kind of like a swastika
type position with their arms and legs
cut off which snakes used as tourniquets
so she's laying there I got to really
create maybe show picture of it I know I
should look for that there's actually
there is some I can't remember the name
of what I was going to say what is that
that disk was at the foot of the stairs
to the sacrificial one of the big
sacrificial pyramids so when you threw
the dead body down those stairs it
landed on that stone yeah that takes a
lot of forethought yeah they're really
thinking about it okay now we have to
have the whole thing that they've wanted
to land on yeah they're reenacting
creation somehow maybe they were doing
something to win it throwing them off
that temple to land there on top of that
thing
so I'm sure something I'm sure you know
one of the archaeologists know more
about what that stone was actually
pulled then you where it was that's kind
of cool there's actually I used to live
in Tampa and there's a museum there what
the hell's the name of is it South
Eastern museums I don't have a natural
history or something like that and they
have a huge collection of Maya Aztecs
Toltecs Olmec all that kind of artwork
and pots and statues and things like
that and it's really cool I mean I
haven't been there for many years but I
remember being really impressed by all
the artifacts they had there so you know
if you're in that area you might wonder
do I see it I guess it's still cool I
haven't been there like I said I've only
seen one big artifact personally that
was at the California of Museum of
Natural History and that was one of the
one of the one of the ass
calendars they've got big one there yeah
they have one in Tampa - huge yeah and
it looks really cool it looks really
cool this in person
now I don't know if they were painted I
think they were painted at one time yeah
that's interesting but one day have in
Tampa is just you know but I don't know
if it had paint on it I do every time I
paint because the the the temples were
yeah I think everything of those painted
just at the pain that they use of course
you know with the modern painted chipped
off well it's just kind of like floored
and we were talking about this the other
day but like a lot of the ancient
Egyptian stuff in ancient greco-roman
stuff they think some of that might have
been painted too but now I always heard
that all painted then I was just kind of
worn off so now we just kind of see
everything is like brown or whatever but
I heard that classic marble look you
know you know like some off of a Joy
Division album cover it everybody explai
super plan yeah that's not the way
that's not what they were going for
that's a modern interpretation all that
paints falling off but really what it
look like there's some tacky it's all
painting and the pubic hair is painted
like something out of a Persian disc
okay that's what it really is that true
because that's hilarious given I felt
like all these years that all these
years people have been thinking about
like how class how class is like look
it's like so beautiful and minimalist
like all the white marble and really it
looked like Jackie Jackie O has all
these crazy wacky colors on it never
does she care painted on the head I love
it I seriously I have much I don't know
if it is but I hope it is evident result
me yeah that's right
all right we're coming up to the end of
the show so we kind of hope you enjoyed
this rather rambling discussion about
mediation yeah we had we have like a
huge long thing and we didn't cover a
lot we didn't cover all right you know
we just run out of time for us but the
idea was is that there's nothing
paranormal about the mine well it's not
a paranormal about any of these things
no just done a paranormal
well they believe in paranormal things
yeah but I mean there was no like
paranormal intervention and they didn't
have magic powers like they have crystal
skulls of many powers not the historical
evidence of the truth about them is even
cooler and weirder that's when these
stories that they made up
that's what I came Industries a lot of
it yeah that's why I kind of wanted to
do the show about them and why I was
glad you suggested it because I always
thought the real [__] about goodbye
about the Maya about the Egyptians and
stuff like that was cool enough yeah
without having to make up stuff about
aliens and all that [__] I know in
the modern portrayal of all those poor
Indians they got taking it nah
those guys were bad they were about that
they were badass proud they were proud
civilization of warriors and they did
all kinds of cool like a wacky [__] and
they look cool they really did yeah yeah
as much as Mel Gibson's kind of a whack
job I do really I did really like
Apocalypto he is awesome and he it
really seemed to take a lot of pain to
get it accurate it's awful at the look
of it as accurate as possible and those
aspect Warriors were portrayed exactly
as the Spaniards described in that those
guys were just monuments to warrior
virtue that there that they were
ruthless ruthless and well-trained
fighters as many as they would have to
be unhappy yeah to live in that circuit
live in this large lot of Asians lots of
decorations and Jade embedded into their
teeth and lots of body modifications and
tattoos and you know they were hardcore
yeah they were cool [__] Lenora core
anyway so that'll do it for this episode
episode 48 and remember in a couple of
weeks we're probably going to be
launching a patreon so be on the lookout
for that all make the big announcement
probably on episode 50 we'll see how it
goes if I get it put up before then also
like I said if you're interested in if
you're interested in Mayan mythology and
you want to read some fiction along that
line
pick up 2012 ad I'll put a link in the
description it's from severed press and
I had a short story in there came out in
2010 obviously because it wanted to come
out before to cash in on the whole 2012
thing but you know storage still good
and do yourself a favor and watch
Apocalypto yeah if you haven't seen it
it's really good but I'm off put a clip
of it at the beginning as a pure
historical action movie no ain't no
English is spoken in it and it they're
not I have to be yeah there's not a
great deal of dialogue that I remember
in all of it yeah another thing
but yet I really liked it I thought it
was a cool look at my week so some of
his other movies I didn't like so much
but I just like the Jesus born yeah
Jesus crucifixion born yeah Passion of
the Christ
yeah I heard this is one big ol long
torch it is it's funny because like
people that would be all up BL into that
film and be like moralizing about and
everything would be like they wouldn't
watch a horror movie but that's
essentially what that is
yeah it's there's a pretty graphic [__]
in there the best the best Bible movies
Noah knew I really yes Darren Aronofsky
one you I like that no no we're - it I
love that was really cool well Darren
air now - yeah we're that's why I'm so
glad to have our Thompson cased
entrapped into your yes I was right
about they just unlike that is he's like
you know what I'm just gonna be here the
goal is going to go with what it says
yeah yeah I'm gonna make it exactly what
it said to people like what just us know
what yes I know that's what it said that
is what is them some made it exactly
like it only that claim from the
apocryphal text what was the name of
that book the Jubilees because there's
more about the flood I keep it right it
was in some of the books that it didn't
make it into the ride I think I might
have been Jubilees a but don't do that
okay
so anyway if you like the show please
like subscribe all that other jazz 13
o'clock in minutes go subscribe to 13
o'clock in minutes which is our new
sister channel there's ten videos up
right now go to the project
Entertainment Network patreon and give
them a buck or two they'll listen to
some of their other podcasts and watch
our patreon and stand by for our patreon
announcement which probably be coming in
a week or two and that'll do it for
episode 48
see you next Tuesday bye oh you asked
[Music]
because of my say it's over soon
the my yes will be welcomed smartly
bother with some all week ride
[Music]